the measure of two angles of an
isosceles triangle or three x plus five
degrees we'll say and x plus 16 degrees
find all possible values of x so let's
think about this let's draw ourselves an
isosceles triangle or two
so it's an isosceles triangle
like that like that and actually let me
draw a couple of them just because we
want to think about all of the different
possibilities here
all of the different possibilities
so we know from what we know about
isosceles triangles that the base angles
are going to be congruent so that side
that angle is going to be equal to that
angle that angle is going to be equal to
that angle
and so what could the 3x plus 5 degrees
and the x plus 16 what could they be
measures of well maybe this one right
over here has a measure of 3x plus 5
degrees and the vertex is the other one
so maybe this one up here is the x plus
16
x plus 16 degrees the other possibility
the other possibility is that this is
describing both base angles in which
case they would be equal so maybe this
one is three x plus five and maybe this
one over here is x plus sixteen
x plus sixteen and that is and then the
final possibility actually we haven't
exhausted all of them is if we swap
these two if this one is x plus 16 and
that one is 3x plus 5. so let me draw
ourselves another triangle
let me draw ourselves another triangle
and obviously swapping these two aren't
going to make a difference because they
are equal to each other and then we can
make that one equal to 3x plus 5 but
that's not going to change anything
either because they're equal to each
other so the last situation
is where this angle down here is x plus
16 and this angle up here is
x plus is three x plus five
this is three x plus five so let's just
work through each of these
so in this situation if this base angle
is 3x plus 5 so is this base angle
and then we know that all three of these
are going to have to add up to 180
degrees so we get 3x
plus 5
plus 3x plus 5
plus x plus 16 plus x plus 16 is going
to be equal to
180 degrees we have 3x let's just add up
the you have 3x plus 3x which gives you
6x plus another x gives you 7x
7x and then you have 5 plus 5 which is
10
plus 16 is equal to 26
is equal to 26 and that is going to be
equal to 180 and then we have let's see
180 minus 26 if we subtract 26 from both
sides we get 180 minus 180 minus 20 is
160
minus another
6 is 154.
150
154 you have 7x is equal to 154.
7x is equal to 154. and let's see how
many times this if we divide both sides
by 7
7 will go into 1 40 20 times and then
you have another 14. so it looks like
it's 22 times so x is equal to 22 is
that right 20 times 7 is 140 140 plus 14
is
154 so we have x is equal to
22 in this first 22 degrees in this
first scenario now let's think about the
second scenario over here
now we have
now we have these two characters are
going to be equal to each other because
they're both the base angles so you have
3x
plus 5 is equal to x plus 16. well you
can subtract x from both sides and so
this becomes 2x plus 5
is equal to 16 we can subtract 5 from
both sides and you get 2x is equal to 11
and then you can divide both sides you
can divide both sides by 2 and you get x
is equal to 11
is equal to 11 halves so that is our
second scenario and then we do our third
scenario right over here if this base
angle is x plus 16 then this base angle
right over here is also going to be x
plus 16. they are congruent and then we
can do the same thing that we did for
the first scenario
all of these angles are going to have to
add up to 180 degrees so we have x plus
16 plus x plus 16
plus 3x plus 5
plus 3x plus 5.
when you add them all together you're
going to get
180 degrees now let's add up all the x
terms x plus x is 2x plus 3x is 5x
so we get 5x
5x and then you have 16 plus 16 is 32
32 plus 5 is 37 plus 37 is equal to 180
degrees
is equal to 180 degrees subtract 37 from
both sides and we get 5x
5x is equal to
180 minus 30 is 150 so that gets us to
143 so it's not going to divide nicely
divide both sides by 5 you get x is
equal to 143
over 5 which we can just leave as an
improper fraction you could write as a
mixed number or however else you might
want to write it and we're done these
are the three
these are the three possible values the
three possible values of x given the
information that they gave us right up
there